[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour un nouveau
numéro du 7-8 échos votre magazine
consacré à l'économie locale tout de
suite le sommaire l'épidémie du colis de
10,9 et ses conséquences économiques
dans les yvelines les entreprises
pourraient être exposés les réactions
les conseils les accompagnements
proposés par les pouvoirs publics à
retrouver dans cette édition
le groupe f des france vient de lancer
son centre de développement des
mobilités du futur l'entreprise ac sol
elle s'est installée sur un nouveau site
de 2500 m² la stratégie autour de ces
nouvelles implantations l'adaptation du
site à l'augmentation de leur activité
en fin 2019 une année dynamique pour
l'immobilier d'entreprise à saint
quentin en yvelines
plus d'une centaine d'opérations
réalisées sur l'année avec des projets
terminés comme l'immeuble le carré ou
des lancements de chantiers comme native
l'activité économique comme je vous
l'indiquais dans les titres est impacté
par la pandémie du coronavirus
confinement des salariés annulation
d'événements de voyage ou rupture de la
chaîne d'approvisionnement d'une
production des phénomènes qui ralentisse
l'activité des entreprises
le gouvernement a annoncé des mesures de
soutien report des échéances sociales et
fiscales étalement des remboursements de
créances ou encore le recours au chômage
partiel écoutez à ce propos
thomas godefroy scola président de la
cpam des yvelines
j'ai pu échanger le dernier traiteur
qu'on a vu mardi il avait une commande
dans le moins faire qu'il allait avoir
un chiffre d'affaires mensuel de 2000
euros qui évidemment lui il va lui
bouffer tout rénové pour tous qui
événementiel la situation est
catastrophique
pareil pour les agences de communication
notamment celles qui font d'événementiel
c'est très compliqué parce que ben y'a
pas à tout est à l'arrêt il n'y a pas de
rassemblement lajux est passé de 1000 à
100 aujourd'hui
donc toutes les activités comme ça
souffrent toutes les activités liées au
tourisme aussi au sens très large
souffre j'ai pu échanger ce matin avec
un chauffeur taxi par exemple qui a une
activité qui est plus que réduite et si
vous êtes chef d'entreprise plusieurs
interlocuteurs possibles pour demander
de l'aide notamment la chambre de
commerce qui propose une adresse mail et
un numéro vert satis en bas de l'écran
de son côté l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines a tenu une réunion
exceptionnelle ce vendredi 13 mars
plusieurs décisions ont été prises suite
au contexte de l'épidémie
l'accueil au ski cube sera notamment
fermés pour le public les ateliers
thématiques seront suspendus puis une
cellule spéciale est mise en place par
le service développement économique
joignable à l'adresse mail et au numéro
de téléphone du ski cube
écoutez à ce propos les détails dan
failli directrice générale adjointe au
développement économique de saint
quentin en yvelines
bien évidemment les entreprises qui sont
accompagnés au sein de ski tubes et qui
bénéficient d'un hébergement continue à
être bien évidemment accueillie et
surtout accompagner et après sur les
mesures qui sont liées à la prise en
charge de leur hébergement etc
toutes les mesures sont mises en place
pour à présent compte de leurs de leurs
besoins particuliers en termes de en
termes de trésorerie et autres tous les
rendez vous individuels avec les
porteurs de projet avec les dirigeants
restent possibles avec les équipes de la
maison de l'entreprise
simplement elle est organisée par par
téléphone et par conférence la situation
est incertaine bien évidemment elle va
évoluer
voilà ce que nous pouvions vous dire par
rapport aux impacts économiques au
niveau local par rapport au corps d'un
virus passons maintenant donc à
l'implantation des entreprises à leur
stratégie le groupe allemand fb est
implantée à saint quentin en yvelines
depuis 2015
spécialisée dans l'ingénierie
l'accompagnement de la démarche est
arrêté des industriels du transport
la filière lait faisait france vient
d'ouvrir un centre de développement des
mobilités du futur sur son site de
trappes un bâtiment de 600 mètres carrés
consacrés au développement des batteries
et des motorisations électriques
regardez nous sommes avec nadim andraos
vice président exécutif de fb france
bonjour bonjour alors avant de parler de
l'implantation de votre nouveau site
dans lequel on se trouve parlant de
l'actualité le coronavirus et ses
conséquences sur l'économie mondiale
vous êtes une multinationale vous est
implanté dans l'ensemble des continents
du monde entier quelles sont les
conséquences directes que vous ressentez
aujourd'hui très bien on a lancé déjà un
task force au niveau international on a
un point régulier chaque matin à 8
heures on a les collègues du chine qui
intervient nous donner leurs
informations
jusqu'à maintenant on a toujours on n'a
pas arrêté la production
mais certainement il faut respecter les
consignes mesurer les températures trois
fois par jour ils sont déjà à ce niveau
là bas et si ici on dépasse les
transepts 2002 la légion elle sombra le
droit de rentrer au site
là on arrive encore à maintenir la
production en chine et en france vous
voyez en continu de la production en
france pas encore d'impact pas pour le
moment
non vous ne mettez vous avez mis en en
place les mesures justes du gouvernement
signe de convergent talent et on va voir
ce qui nous attendait 6 à la semaine
prochaine ça évolue rapidement
elle aurait fugué france est une
multinationale spécialisée dans
l'ingénierie dans la recherche et
développement de l'industrie du
transport
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer en
quoi ça consiste donc les racines venait
de développement de la combustion en
1978 et ça évolue rapidement d'une
manière qu'aujourd'hui pour faire face
aux enjeux environnementaux et
politiques
on a avancé un petit peu nos
développements on a renforcé nos
activités du point du vue ingénierie du
véhicule tout ce qui est électrification
de la chaîne de traction complète tout
ce qui est en plus véhicules connectés
et véhicule autonome vous lancer ce site
le centre de développement de la
mobilité du futur
qu'est ce qui va se passer ici donc nos
activités c'est d'accompagner les
constructeurs se tout ce qui est
traction électrique et là aussi on
mesure tous leurs batteries
donc c'est à dire on commence par les
mesures des cellules après les packs et
les modules et les packs complets
combien de personnes vont travailler ici
donc sur ce bâtiment là on est à peu
près une douzaine de personnes ça fait
déjà cinq plus que cinq ans qu'on a
commencé cette activité
au début elle était au centre au milieu
de notre bâtiment mais certainement il
faut respecter certaines normes c'est
pour ça on a déménagé tout ici on a
presque multiplié par dix la capacité
avant nous étions à ces cellules on est
passé à 100 oui cellule pour accompagner
le développement rapide de la laiterie
fication en france
oui vous parlez de cinq ans parce que
vous êtes en plantes et attrapes depuis
2000 15 ans et demi 15 voilà donc là
le groupe a démarré ses activités en
france en 2005 et en 2015 on a racheté
la boîte d2t dans le temps et on évolue
rapidement donc on est presque une
croissance de 20% annuel depuis 2015
c'est un territoire stratégique je
suppose parce que on voit beaucoup
d'acteurs de l'automobile présent est
installé sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
c'est c'est un endroit vraiment
stratégiques
nous avons le technocentre de renault
qui est à côté
nos avants peugeot implantée à carrières
sous poissy il ya d autres encore
fournisseurs qui sont dans le coin
donc c'est un point vraiment stratégique
pour nous concrètement vous travaillez
comment avec le technocentre par exemple
parce que c'est vraiment ça le coeur de
leur activité c'est la recherche et
développement autour du véhicule
voilà on les accompagne dans tous ce
domaine je peux pas rentrer en détail au
delà de ça désolé c'est ce confidentiel
c'est ça oui c'est clair comment vous
travaillez finalement c'est vous faites
quoi vous fait de l'accompagnement vous
allez mettre en place des systèmes pour
tester des prototypes comment ça se
passe donc on peut mettre des systèmes
comme vous venez de le dire mais en plus
on peut au delà de ça même développé des
prototypes pour eux quel regard vous
avez sur la mobilité du futur vous donc
certainement il faut l'accompagner c'est
une évolution qui rapide
actuellement on a passé dans les étapes
de l'hybride on va passer partir parce
qu'après o'clock in hybrid et se
rapprocher à fur et à mesure de tout ce
qui est l édification de la chaîne de
traction
c'est un nouveau site une nouvelle
implantation c'est quoi la stratégie
qu'il ya derrière
quelle stratégie a derrière la stratégie
économique la stratégie de l'entreprise
avec ce nouveau site avec ce nouveau si
c'est certainement l'accompagnement de
la transition au niveau de la chaîne de
traction et certainement on va le
développer au fur et à mesure c'est ce
que vous voyez c'est juste la partie qui
est l'hérault au casting des batteries
mais il ya encore le moteur électrique
tout ce qui est autour de six axes ça
c'est dans l'autre bâtiment on va pas
parler aujourd'hui
quel avenir quelles sont les
perspectives d'avenir de développement
de ff france donc comme j'ai dis donc
depuis 2015 on est en croissance à peu
près 2
20% lors de ma % annuels on va le
maintenir à ce niveau et être toujours
présent sur ce secteur nadim andros
merci beaucoup merci bien vice président
exécutif de fb france saint quentin en
yvelines c'est un parc d'immobilier
d'entreprise de 4,6 millions de mètres
carrés le deuxième pôle économique d'île
de france attire de nombreuses
entreprises avec une activité dynamique
sur le marché de l'immobilier en 2019
regardez
[Musique]
e
elle était d'abord implanté dans le
garage de son créateur puis à plaisir
elle est maintenant installé sur un site
de 2500 m² à trappes 600 m² de bureaux
et 1800 m² d'entrepôts cette société ces
axes hall une entreprise spécialisée
dans la vente et la location de matériel
d'accessibilité pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite une activité en pleine
croissance
regardez ce reportage nous avons ici un
produit que nous importons il diffuse en
europe qui est une chenillette
tout-terrain la distribution de matériel
destiné à l'accessibilité des personnes
en situation de handicap en france et en
europe la spécialité de l'entreprise ac
sol installée depuis novembre 2010 neuf
sur ce site de 2500 m² à trappes
on avait besoin à la fois de d'agrandir
les espaces de bureaux et de show room
pour recevoir nos clients mais également
toute la surface de stockage et
entrepôts l'idée c'est d'anticiper le
développement futur d'avoir une marge de
gier a une marge de progression sans
avoir à bouger
jean-paul mignard a créé cette société
en 2010 d'abord dans son garage il
s'installe ensuite dans des locaux à
plaisir aujourd'hui ils sont quinze
salariés réalise environ 2,2 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires rampe
d'accès dispositif pour monter les
escaliers plateforme élévatrice des
produits importés et stockés dans ce
nouvel entrepôt plus grand que l'ancien
ça me facilite grandement la vie ne
serait ce que pour les inventaires qui
sont vachement plus fiable de par la
possibilité de rangement de l'entrepôt
où les choses sont bien définis à des
endroits clair et net
après avoir déménagé on a réussi à tout
bien définir les zones de location
duck les états chez les gens de stockage
de picking et puis de l'étiquetage et du
zonage d'entrepôt pour savoir où est
rangé quoi dans sa stratégie
d'implantation axle a aménagé un espace
de coworking du mobilier une connexion
internet et une salle de réunion avec
une zone de l'entrepôt pour du stockage
mises à disposition pour des
entrepreneurs
ça me paraît tout à fait naturel après
avoir moi développer mon entreprise et
on a encore beaucoup de choses à faire
d'accompagner des jeunes créateurs ou
repreneurs d'entreprise avec une
croissance moyenne de 30% par an axle
vise les 2 5 millions d'euros en 2020
avec à l'horizon le développement de
projets autour des jeux olympiques de
paris en 2024
avant de se quitter je vous rappelle la
mise en place d'une cellule spéciale par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
l'adresse mail s'affiche en bas d'écran
dvico @ the sky au point fr vous pouvez
aussi contacter le ski cubes si vous
avez notamment des questions sur le
coronavirus ou sur l'organisation et les
conséquences que peuvent avoir cette
épidémie sur l'activité de votre
entreprise c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de nous avoir suivis et à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]